[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' à tanis
d'interdire je reçois aujourd'hui
l'historien et archéologue laurent
olivier pour ce qui est arrivé à windows
ni qui vient de paraître chez flammarion
une enquête sur le dernier massacre
d'indiens aux états unis en décembre
1890 par les soldats du 7e de cavalerie
et je reçois également l'écrivain benoît
duteurtre qui publie chez gallimard ma
vie extraordinaire là plutôt qu'une
enquête il s'agit d'une quête d'une
quête du merveilleux jusque dans la
banalité de la vie dit le quatrième de
couverture mais commençons tout de suite
par notre époque qu'est ce qui
caractérise ce début de xxième siècle
voici votre réponse en images benoît
duteurtre est-ce que vous pouvez nous la
commenter j'ai ma petite idée mais je
préfère que ce soit vous qu'ils disaient
non mais je les ai vécus en plus je
sortais l'autre jour de la gare saint
lazare et on a descendu avec un taxi
l'avenue de l'opéra et tout d'un coup
en plus si c'était un peu le soir
c'était glauque il y avait ces grands
murs de béton couvert de tags seiplo
hideux à moitié tordu par pour les uns
tout ça au milieu de l'avenue de l'opéra
avec au fond le palais garnier est quand
même une des plus belles images de paris
l'alignement des immeubles sis parisien
également et tout d'un coup je vous dis
mes clics ou est ce que je suis ce que
je suis à beyrouth peut-être dans une
ville en guerre civile ou alors encore
dans une ville du tiers monde on n'a
jamais fini les travaux qu'on avait
commencé et nous on était à paris au
coeur de paris de ce beau pari et je me
suis dit mais c'est quand même
extraordinaire ce qu'on peut créer comme
laideur au nom du bien
si vous voulez parce que ça c'est pour
protéger la planète et pour protéger les
cyclistes sauf qui avait pas de
cyclistes d'ailleurs comme pas plus que
sur cette photo et comment est-ce qu'on
peut quoi la vandaliser une ville au nom
d'une bonne cause mais on pourrait
élargir assez notre époque parce qu'on
pourrait me dire ça par exemple certains
paysages recouverts d'éoliennes par
exemple comment est-ce qu'on peut créer
autant de laideur au nom du bien et
comment est-ce qu'on peut créer donc une
espèce de mal
qui est qui est parfois pire que ce
qu'on a voulu éviter
voilà c'est d'autant plus intéressant
que ce soit venue de l'opéra c'est que
vous savez la carte caractéristiques de
cette avenue
c'est la seule à paris qu'il a pas
d'arbres et pourquoi il n'y a pas
d'arbres aviv le perso j'aimerais
justement pour respecter cette
perspective dont napoléon iii était si
fier avec le
avec l'opéra jusqu'au bout voilà
et effectivement maintenant il ya
beaucoup de jaune il ya toujours peu de
pâte de verre meilleur aloïs jaune là il
est il est terrible je rends olivier
votre image à vous la voici
et bien c'est une image intemporel c'est
une image de 1902 scellier ta indienne
pima d'arizona l'état c'est pas son nom
c'est pas comment elle s'appelle pima
c'est pas le nom de son peuple pimas et
pimac ça veut dire je sais pas je
comprends pas et on l'a affublée d'une
robe à froufrous c'est une europe qui
appartient à une dame qui n'en voulait
plus pour cacher ses seins et malgré
cela malgré cette laideur lieta est
belle et c'est une image qui montre
al'inverse de l'image de l'opéra que la
beauté fini par triompher toujours de la
laideur de l'oppression de la domination
on ne parvient pas à rendre à l'état
l'aide et bien commençons
[Musique]
l'heureux livier je n'ai dit vous êtes
historia hier que le log vous êtes
conservateur en chef au musée
d'archéologie nationale de saint germain
en laye vous avez travaillé toute votre
vie sur les gaulois
alors pourquoi cet intérêt soudain pour
lee hsiu et le massacre de wounded knee
c'est pas un intérêt soudain c'est
quelque chose qui s'enracine dans dans
l'enfance ce qui m'intéresse c'est ce
que c'est ce que révèle l'archéologie de
l'histoire l'histoire parle des
événements et l'archéologie révèle ce
qui s'est passé ce que les gens ont fait
et ce qu'on a fait aux gens et et ciu
comme les indiens sont deux peuples qui
ont été des peuples dominant des peuples
guerrier et puis qui ont été vaincus
dominé et dont la culture a été
progressivement détruites ils ont perdu
leurs institutions leur langue leur
culture et ce qui m'intéressait dans
gouttes de tni c'est que ça s'est passé
non payet de milan mais il ya 130 ans et
c'était c'est l'actualité de ce massacre
qui m'intéressait ce qu'il en reste ce
qu'il en reste comment comment ça
résonne encore dans les mémoires
collectives dans ce monde is you mais
aussi des américains
qu'est ce que ça révèle de cette sorte
de trou noir qui est qui et les
rééducations des populations autochtones
autour desquels gravitent l'histoire
américaine en quelque sorte c'est
tellement récente d'ailleurs qu'on va
voir beaucoup de photos défilé derrière
moi parce qu'il y ait des photos de
cette époque on né le 29 décembre 1890
où en sont les sioux exactement leur
leur puissance a été quasiment réduite à
néant à ce moment là bas les sioux entre
la fin du xviiie siècle et le début du
19ème force qu'on peut faire ce qu'on
peut appeler une sorte d'empiré ils
s'étendent sur presque un cinquième du
territoire des etats unis
il contrôle l'accès du économique du
missouri et progressivement avec avec
l'arrivée des colons américains alors
leur territoire va se réduire
et puis à l'issue des guerres indiennes
va y avoir certes la grande victoire de
little big horn mais ils vont être des
faits est enfermé dans des réserves
et peu à peu le bison va être qu'il
ressource vitale va être détruit leurs
institutions
annihiler leurs enfants envoyés dans les
écoles et il ya un moment de désespoir
1890 et il arrive comme à plusieurs
moments de l'histoire américaine un
mouvement messianique c'est le messie
est apparu c'est le christ le christ
leur dit qu il sait il est arrivé pour
les blancs mais il met les blancs l'ont
crucifié et maintenant il est le dieu
des indiens le bilan va revenir les
blancs vont disparaître le monde va
renaître tel qu'il était et les
américains prennent peur de ceux de ce
mouvement qui promet leur éradication et
en envoie l'armée dans les réserves pour
chercher les meneurs et pour les emmener
les angles en captivité et c'est à ce
moment que que va se déclencher le
massacre de wounded knee qui est à
l'origine des aînés n'est pas prévu on
arraisonnent une troupe d'environ 300 à
400 personnes
une troupe d'indiens lakota des sioux
donc qui se déplace d'une réserve à une
autre et l'armée les captures en tant
que prisonnier de guerre
donc non seulement les vieillards mais
aussi les des enfants et les nouveaux
nés et s'apprêtent elles et à désarmer
des hommes et à déporter toute la
population à environ 800 km de là à fort
roma on les voit d'ailleurs ils sont
derrière moi les les ces indiens la côte
à leur chef c'est bill foot où en sont
les chefs d d d indiens à ce moment là
big foot on le connaît pas très bien
mais malheureusement il va mourir dans
ce massacre mais où en sont sitting bull
geronimo ils sont encore vivants ce
moment là mais mais ils sont désarmés
beaucoup sont morts beaucoup sont vieux
aussi un sitting bull
une soixantaine d'années s'est finie la
guerre et les sociétés guerrière sous
son sont terminés donc les guerriers non
non non non plus de raison d'être et des
chefs spirituels
soit on rejoint la coopération avec les
l'armée américaine soit
sont en retraite et la plupart vivent
relativement misérablement
c'est l'époque de la grande ourse ue est
déterminé en 1890 alors vous l'avez dit
c'est sous et leur chef bigfoot sont
sont arrêtés envoyé à windows ni qui est
un poste dans le dakota le dakota du sud
et là il ya un climat de psychose qui
s'installe parmi les blancs vous en avez
expliqué la raison on a l'impression que
il ya une nouvelle fièvre indienne mais
aussi parmi les journalistes et je te
dire que pendant toutes ces guerres
indiennes le rôle des journalistes a été
particulièrement important à la fois
pour grossir les événements en faire d
en faire des batailles extraordinaire là
où il y avait généralement quelques
échauffourées en parlant de massacre de
deux fermiers blancs alors qu'il y avait
à peine un mort et un blessé
on a l'impression que toute la presse
américaine à l'époque ne raconte que des
fêtes news et à chaque fois transforme
des moments finalement parfois
anecdotiques en épopée ce qui est très
intéressant à ce moment en 1890 et que
c'est vraiment l'entrée de l'amérique
dans le dans la modernité
c'est le moment où les agences de presse
agence havas prend son essor
donc grâce au telegraph une nouvelle
peut se répandre presque instantanément
dans le dans le monde entier la nouvelle
du mexique deux gouttes de ti sera connu
dès le lendemain dans toute l'europe et
eva suscité une vague d'indignation
france par exemple et c'est aussi c'est
tout à fait intéressant c'est aussi le
début du journalisme on dirait
aujourd'hui mbe dead les journalistes
accompagnent l'armée pour rendre compte
de l'événement qui est la grande
reddition définitive des sioux donc il
ya ce côté très contemporain en fait
dans lesquelles les journalistes la
presse en l'occurrence est directement
associée aux événements militaires alors
avec évidemment l'idée pour l'armée il
ya une arrière pensée derrière ça qui
est de faire connaître le rôle
pacificateur de l'armée et puis aussi
le grand instigateur de tout cela qui
s'appelle général miles nelson miles a
tout de suite compris le rôle de rôle
que peut jouer la presse pour lui parce
que effectivement en grossissant ces
événements en les livrant au lectorat de
toute l'amérique
on consacre aussi la carrière
la future carrière du général maisky qui
vise dit-on la présidence des états unis
alors qu'est ce qui se passe exactement
avoue denis on l'a dit ils veulent
désarmer les sioux ils les emmènent dans
ce poste il ya big foot il ya plusieurs
centaines d'indiens qui sont rassemblés
là il ya le septième de cavalerie il va
y avoir un massacre qu'est-ce qu'il est
déclenché c'est ce qu'on appelle une
bavure c'est à dire qu'à l'origine
l'idée c'est d'arraisonner ses troupes
de 2 300 à 400 personnes pour les
emmener à des tensions sans leur dire en
fait on leur laisse croire qu'ils vont
aller à l'endroit auquel ils se rendent
qui est la réserve de pine ridge qui se
trouve près de 150 kilomètres de leurs
propres réserves et que pour ce faire
ils vont le faire sous escorte
américaine mais que pour cela on a
besoin que les guerriers soit désarmé et
en fait on leur explique pas que cette
histoire de désarmement sans fait des
prisonniers de guerre c'est à dire des
gens qui sont aux mains de la de l'armée
des états unis et donc au moment du
départ ont de vous convoquer un conseil
les hommes les guerriers pour leur
expliquer qu'ils doivent livrer leurs
armes et les guérit comprennent pas très
bien pourquoi est-ce que c'est urgent de
livrer des armes alors que on est censé
partir pour pinebridge et puis donc ce
désarmement se fait de mauvaise grâce
on va dire et puis un moment on ne sait
pas on ne sait pas d'où c'est venu un
coup de feu est tiré il vient très
probablement du coup du côté indien et
puis une fusillade se déclenche la
plupart des hommes rassemblent au
conseil qui est donc avaient été séparés
des hommes et des femmes sont tuées
un mouvement de panique se déclenche
dans le dans le campement donc chez les
femmes et des enfants
à ce moment-là l'artillerie d'artillerie
légère bombarde le campement avec des
obus
à mitraille les survivants reflue vers
pour se cacher dans un ravin qui se
trouve
voilà que voilà qui se trouve au pied du
campement et là ils sont complètement de
copiage ils peuvent pas en sortir et ils
sont systématiquement abattu par l'armée
américaine
donc en fait à l'issue de ces journées
c'est non seulement un échec
extraordinaire de la manoeuvre de
désarmement
c'est une tueriie d'indiens mais c'est
aussi un gros problème du point de vue
de l'armée parce qu'il ya tout de même
une trentaine de morts et de blessés du
côté américain
il va donc y avoir une enquête une
enquête interne va être diligentée par
par l'armée pour comprendre pourquoi
est-ce qu'ils aient eu autant de morts
est en fait la la c'est là où c'est
intéressant parce que c'est à ce moment
là que la vérité boon de tni va se créer
dans dans cette thèse de défense de
l'armée
les les officiers américains et un
officier supérieur vont dire qu'en fait
ils ont été surpris par le tir en masse
des indiens ont suggérant que les
indiens leur avait tiré dessus
par dizaines et que donc ils ont été
obligés de répliquer ils sont trouvés
dans une situation de légitime défense
quelque sorte et puis en voulant
annihiler les poches de résistance
formée par des guerriers des snipers qui
leur tirait dessus
étant donné que les guérit se sont
mélangés aux femmes et aux enfants il ya
eu ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui des
dommages collatéraux
on a tué quelques femmes et enfants en
essayant d'éliminer cccc poste de
résistance ça c'est la version qui va
être la version 2000 en ta version
relayée par la presse qui va en faire un
événement magnifier et puis on va avoir
soin aussi du côté de l'armée de
transformer cet événement évidemment l
enquête l aider à l'issue d'une enquête
au cours de laquelle on prendra bien
soin de ne pas interroger les hommes du
rang ni les officiers intermédiaires qui
ont transcrit transmis les ordres des
officiers supérieurs aux soldats à
l'issue de cette enquête le septième de
cavalerie ressortira blanchi il ya eu
des morts indien ce sont des effets
collatéraux
il ya beaucoup de morts dans les rangs
américains c'est parce qu'on a dû
essuyer un d'un un feu indien très
important et c'est tout et on va
transformer cette événement dans les
dents dans les mois qui vont suivre en
un événement héroïque les soldats du 7e
de cavalerie rosso
20 médailles d'honneur c'est la plus
haute distinction militaire américaine
et aujourd'hui vous ne teniez élan des
engagements militaires les plus décorés
de toute l'histoire américaine
par comparaison d'idées le débarquement
où un nombre infiniment supérieur
d'hommes et sont engagés c'est seulement
quatre médailles d'honneur
donc en fait vous ne teniez va être
transformé en une sorte de victoire
américaine dans la victoire la
civilisation américaine sur la
sauvagerie indienne alimenté par cette
espèce de fièvre delà de la ghost dance
de fièvre ce mouvement messianique
on voit en photo derrière moi des images
véritablement de cette époque là sont
les cadavres des guerriers qui sont
emportés on a vu juste avant la
l'ancêtre de la mitrailleuse en fait
avec laquelle les les soldats ont tiré
sur sur les indiens ccc voilà c'est tout
c'est avec cette arme là on a énormément
de deux témoignages votre enquête vous
l'avez fait à partir de quoi on va voir
d'ailleurs derrière moi le cadavre de
delhomme médecine que on accuse d'avoir
été le déclencheur celui qui aurait tiré
le premier qui a été tué pendant ce
massacre
vous avez travaillé sur quoi vous êtes
un archéologue vous fouillez normalement
vous fouiller la terre
alors ce que j'ai fait en fait c'est
c'est un travail élémentaires qui
curieusement n'avait pas été réalisé cet
événement en fait été prévu comme
quelque chose de qu'ils devaient marcher
gens diraient vulgairement comme sur des
roulettes les indiens devait se livrer
on devait les emmener et tout ça devait
se passer très facilement
en fait ça ne s'est pas du tout passé de
cette manière-là mais il ya eu beaucoup
de témoins qui assistaient à l'événement
les officiers de l'armée on a les
témoignages qui ont été recueillis au
moment de l' enquête on a des badauds on
a des journalistes et puis on a le
témoignage des survivants il ya eu tout
de même une portion relativement
importante de deux personnes qui a pu
survivre des survivants lakota et j'ai
fait j'ai fait un travail de base qui
est qui et de recouper tous ces
témoignages decaux comme dans une
enquête criminelle afin de reconstituer
la chronologie très très précise des
évènements heure après heure après heure
est donc ça permet de reconstituer le
fil des événements et puis de voir qu'en
fait la version qui a été défendu par
l'armée bat elle ne tient pas à l'examen
des faits et celle qui est la plus
vraisemblable c'est celle qu'on a
malheureusement pas écouté c'est celle
des survivants indien qui disent qu'en
réalité il ya eu vraiment des tirs en
masse à la fois sûre sur le campement
et puis ensuite sur les gens qui
s'étaient qui s'étaient réfugiés à
l'intérieur du ravin c'est une tuerie ce
n'est pas une bataille c'est comme ça
d'ailleurs que la voyait le général maï
ce qui a immédiatement voulu suspendre
de ses fonctions forsythe qui est le
responsable de ce massacre a été forcé
de va passer devant une commission d
enquête va être acquitté
et puis finalement comme vous l'avez
raconté on va on va faire de tous ceux
de tout ça un acte héroïque on va
distribuer des medal of honor
pour que pour qu'on garde le souvenir
d'un acte de guerre d'un acte héroïque
c'est fou d'ailleurs quand on regarde
les guerres indiennes à quel point on a
fait d'actes héroïques de bataille
prestigieuse de grandes batailles d'aidé
là encore j'assiste des choses qui était
tout petit
c'est à dire que les les grandes
batailles dont se sont si fiers les
américains c'est c'est quoi ces trente
morts 60 morts 70 morts c'est rien par
rapport à ce qu'on connaissait au même
moment en europe
or depuis deux siècles y vivent sur
l'illusion qu'ils se sont bâtis dans la
violence
alors qu'une violence dérisoire par
rapport à ce qu'on connaît au même
moment nous et puis surtout ce sont des
guerres qui hissa les guerres indiennes
sont des guerres qui s'inspire des
guerres modernes les guerres indiennes
tire beaucoup l'expérience de la guerre
de sécession
et puis d'une autre guerre sur laquelle
il ya de nombreux observateurs
militaires américains c'est la guerre
franco-prussienne de 1870
ce sont deux guerres modernes c'est à
dire ce sont des guerres dans laquelle
d'artillerie joue un rôle très important
sont des guerres dans lesquelles les
attaques sur les villes au cid et les
civils deviennent essentielles et ce
sont des guerres dans lesquelles se
développe une nouvelle stratégie une
nouvelle tactique militaire c'est à dire
que on ne fera plus la guerre à
l'ancienne dans laquelle on rencontre
des demi sur le champ de bataille mais
on va s'en prendre à sa manne
subsistance on va détruire ces récoltes
on va détruire son économie on va
massacrer ces populations civiles
et lorsqu'il sera son champ de bataille
il sera déjà complètement affaibli et à
ce moment là par une disproportion de
force on l'écrasera donc cesser cette
idée de la guerre totale en fait été de
la guerre contre les civils qui
s'applique en fait aux guerres indiennes
dans lesquels on commence par détruire
effectivement le bison puisque c'est le
russell leurs ressources économiques
et puis il ya cette idée de la
disproportion de la force et à dire que
on utilise effectivement de l'artillerie
légère vous avez montré les canons
hotchkiss de fabrication française pour
tirer sur des femmes et des enfants
avec cet effet qu' un effet qui est tout
à fait américain qui est admirable de ce
point de vue là c'est je dirais c'est la
transformation vous avez pas des
journalistes mais il ya le spectacle et
la transformation de l'histoire en un
spectacle
par l'intermédiaire de buffalo bills par
exemple et de son voile d'ouest chaud
les guerres indiennes devienne un
spectacle les buffalo bills va faire
rejouer cette bataille avec des grosses
guillemets de woods de tni dans lesquels
comme dans un cirque un les indiens
réattaque la diligence et à chaque fois
la cavalerie arrive et puis dispersés
indien qui s'incline devant devant la
vole la supériorité militaire américaine
il ya une mise en scène de l'histoire
qui s'effectuent les cirques comme la
presse de l'époque d'ailleurs va établir
au fond le mythe du far west et le mythe
des guerres indiennes
enfin le mythe elles ont existé les
guerres indiennes mais on va aller on va
aller on va en faire quelque chose de
beaucoup plus gros que sanaa était
comment on va populariser l'idée des
duels dans la rue alors qu'on en connaît
qu'un et que billy the kid dont on fait
un bandit terrible a tué beaucoup moins
de gens que la bande à bonnot tout ça au
fond les cirques la presse pile cinéma
ensuite va faire une épopée de quelque
chose qui au fond est de l'ordre de
quelques faits divers
oui est ce qui est tout à fait
intéressant avec avec cet épisode de
green de tni on disait tout à l'heure
que sa maman tu bascules c'est le moment
où l'amérique rentrer dans la modernité
c'est aussi le moment où le cinéma
commence à se développer et justement
les vieux spectacle du buffalo bills ils
sont usés et les vieux spectacle de
cirque le le futur l'avenir c'est de
celle western c'est le cinéma et on va
justement william cody avec nelson miles
vont monter un film qui s'appelle indian
wells le foot les guerres indiennes
combattu à nouveau dans lequel on va
reconstituer la bataille entre
guillemets de windows ni et l'armée
va financer ce film pour produire un
document d'archivé en réalité pour que
dans le futur les chercheurs puissent
consulter ce film comme une recréation
de dell de l'histoire c'est tout à fait
intéressant aussi sur la manière dont
l'amérique fabrique sa propre histoire
le bats akron woods dit c'est quand on
lit votre livre on voit bien que c'est
le c'est l'aboutissement au fond d'une
d'un processus de déshumanisation des
indiens à la fois les indiens les hommes
les guerriers mais aussi leurs femmes
leurs enfants les vieillards
c'est parce qu'on les a désarmés anisé
pendant si longtemps qu'on peut les
massacrer comme on l'a fait ce jour là
est ce que pour autant aujourd'hui on
accuse la mérite d'avoir commis un
génocide là à les garder à l'égard des
indiens est ce que vous pensez que s'il
s'agit d'un génocide le massacre de
masse en fait il n'est il n'est pas
prémédité mais il n'arrive pas par
hasard en fait il y les préparer et les
préparé par toute une série de mesures
juridiques qui le rendent possible
c'est ça qui fait la spécificité des
génocides
c'est pas tellement le massacre
l'extermination d'elle-même c'est le
fait que il se déclenche souvent de
manière inopinée à parce que il ya un
tout un terrain qu'il a préparée et en
fait les indiens les amérindiens sont
sont déshumanisés progressivement par
toute une série de mesures juridiques
la première d'entre elles c'est dès les
années 1830 on les définit comme des ce
qu'on appelle des nations intérieur
dépendantes un espèce d'oxymore ils sont
étrangers ne sont pas américains ne
parlent pas la langue américaine n'ont
pas la culture américaine mais en même
temps ils sont sur le territoire
américain donc ils sont sujets américain
et donc dès le début on commence par
étiqueté le fait que leur politique
extérieure leurs rapports avec leurs
voisins ils n'en n'ont plus le
l'autonomie ça ressort de la politique
américaine
et puis il ya toute une série de procès
qui sont livrés dans le courant des
années 1850 1860 et 70 ou petit à petit
on en arrive à la conclusion que
l'indien n'est pas une personne l'indien
est un sujet mais il n'a pas les mêmes
droits que ceux des autres américains il
ne peut pas circuler librement il est il
est enfermé à l'intérieur des réserves
si bien que à partir du monde le
massacre se déclenche en fait il a été
rendu possible non seulement par la
ségrégation mais aussi par le rejet et
par le déclassement de de ce que
représente l'indien ceux qui méritent de
vivre et de prospérer c'est les
américains ceux qui doivent s'effacer
devant le progrès ce sont les indiens et
à un moment d'ailleurs les ordres de
l'armée sont claires un sait s'il
résiste détruisez l'est et c'est cela ou
d'ethnie c'est à dire c'est un petit
accident
quelque chose qui ressemble à un
soubresaut de résistance et c'est la
destruction de deux buts du dernier
groupe d'aidé lakota alors la question
du génocide la question génocide est
extrêmement importante parce que en fait
c'est une notion très complexe à
utiliser
c'est une notion à la fois juridique et
une notion à la fois historique
c'est ce qui fait sa faiblesse lemkin
qui a défini la notion de génocide en a
fait une une notion juridique en disant
il ya le crime d'homicide quand on tue
un individu ou une personne et il ya le
crime de génocide quand on tue une
population est évidemment toute la
question qui se pose devient dès lors
c'est de la préméditation est ce que est
ce que le crime était prémédité ou pas
et dans la plupart des cas elle ne l'est
pas nécessairement
c'est pourquoi les chercheurs
aujourd'hui qui le 20e siècle a été très
riche en en massacrant génocide de
toutes sortes
les chercheurs du xxème siècle préfère
de parler parler de processus
génocidaire plutôt que de génocide
et dans le cas de woods tenir on est
vraiment dans un processus génocidaire
c'est-à-dire dans dans quelque chose qui
qui qui est là pour pour dénier toute
l'humanité
aux indiens faire en sorte qu'il n'est
pas un statut d'humain normal et c'est
ce déclassement qui explique qu'à un
moment le massacre peut se déclencher
merci l'heureux olivier votre livre
vient de paraître aux éditions
flammarion ont fait une pause et on se
retrouve juste après avec benoît
duteurtre
[Musique]
mais note du tartre vous êtes écrivain
vous avez publié plus de 30 livres dont
un certain nombre de romans plus ou
moins autobiographique
pourquoi cette envie soudaine à 60 ans
de raconter votre vie votre vraie vie
pas tout à fait soudaines comme vous
l'avez dit j'ai écrit un certain nombre
de livres plus ou moins autobiographique
même pas mal autobiographique ces
dernières années j'ai évoqué voilà
l'histoire de famille les vacances
normande et cetera les enthousiasmes de
l'adolescence et voilà jeudi avec ce
livre là y est c'est plutôt un petit peu
l'aboutissement de toute cette série le
lit où je raconte ma propre histoire
mais c'est peut-être que plus développé
dans le genre effectivement alors est ce
que c'est parce que j'ai 60 ans je me
disais voilà faut que je parle de tout
ce dont j ai pas parlé encore et il ya
aussi il y avait aussi l'idée que
finalement on écrit beaucoup sur sa
jeunesse sur son apprentissage et puis
après il ya tout le milieu de la vie de
20 ans jusqu'à 60 ans justement qui est
une espèce de tourbillon il se passe
mille choses mais qui sont pas faciles à
raconter je me suis dit voilà il faut
que j'essaie aussi de trouver les fils
comme ça pour raconter aussi ce que
c'est que l'âge adulte et pas seulement
le roman d'apprentissage même s'il ya
aussi cette dimension dans ce livre là
quand on raconte sa vie on est obligé de
se demander qui ça va intéresser
et alors vous avez vos lecteurs et ils
sont d'un certain nombre mais on doit se
sentir modeste parce que la vie que vous
racontez c'est une vie tout ce qu'elle
plus banal c'est pas une vie pleine de
rebondissements d' aventure vous ne
risquez pas votre vie a pas pour pour
aller chercher vos clés que vous avez
oublié dans l'appartement d'à côté mais
je veux dire c'est pas plein de
rebondissements important et au moment
où vous l'écrivez vous vous devez
forcément vous demandez qui ça va c'est
ma vie bien évidemment d'ailleurs c'est
un livre dans le titre lui-même
et là je pense d'auto ironie ça
s'appelle ma vie extraordinaire parce
que ma vie n'est pas extraordinaire
c'est une vie finalement effectivement
banal par certains aspects et mon idée
c'était de trouver dans cette banalité
qu'est ce qu'il ya d'extraordinaire est
d'essayer de faire partager aux lecteurs
donc notamment toute la première partie
du livre ce seront les enchantements de
l'enfance et découvertes merveilleuses
notamment de la nature puisque vivre se
passe beaucoup dans la région des vosges
où j'ai passé toutes ses vacances
d'enfant
et puis de certains personnages comme ça
qu'ils vont vous vous formez vous
façonner et qui vont resurgir tout au
long de votre vie alors évidemment c'est
une expérience banal mais en même temps
c'est une expérience universelle aura
certes un sens donc j'essaye au fil de
ce livre est de la même façon on vous le
disiez tout à l'heure quand pour parler
de ma vie d'adulte j'explique que ma
principale activité ça a consisté à
chercher mes lunettes et mes clés dont
je ne savais pas où je les avais posé
dans l'appartement c'est évidemment pas
une grande épopée je le reconnais mais
c'est une expérience que tout le monde a
et qu'on peut raconter avec humour et
j'essaye comme ça voilà de tout au long
de ma vie de trouver des fils qui qui
qui peuvent être partagées par tous les
lecteurs et en même temps donc de
brosser un autoportrait qui est par
lui-même qui a par lui-même sa sa beauté
son intérêt qui tient moins aux actions
de ma vie mais qui à la façon dont les
choses sont sont pas tous en raconter
est ce que vous êtes aperçu avec elles
peuvent vous présentiez dans ce livre
comme un anti héros un peu poltron un
peu bougon obsédé par les chaussettes
dépareillées et au plus doté d'une
libido
assez assez faible c'est le mot que vous
employez à un certain moment d'ailleurs
pourquoi oui dans le livre mais bien sûr
c'est effectivement je le redis l'idée
de ce livre c'est de se montrer avec une
part d'autodérision de montrer ce que
c'est effectivement aucune vie d'un
homme moderne post moderne qui va avoir
des ambitions littéraires dans une
époque et la fin du xxème siècle comment
ça se passe comment ça réussit comment
ça échoue souvent aussi c'était bien
cette vérité là que j'avais envie de
raconter
compris en confrontant parfois mais mes
grandes ambitions à une réalité moins
extraordinaire mais c'est justement bien
le jeu même de ce livre et c'est par
cette façon de les raconter des choses
que je pense que chacun peut d'une
certaine façon aussi c'est s'y retrouver
aussi comparer d'une certaine façon mais
j'ai remarqué vous épancher pas
tellement sûr au fond ce qui fait le
coeur en général de l'autobiographie à
savoir l'argent l'amour et la renommée
et et toutes les stratégies dont on est
capable à la fois pour les obtenir
ou pour les conserver et au fond vous
êtes assez discret surtout ça oui enfin
bon je parle quand même de deux maisons
de jeu de ces fameuses ambitions
littéraires et de la façon dont je rêve
pendant des années d'une reconnaissance
qui n'arrive pas parce qu'en plus je
suis un petit peu décalé dans mes romans
réalistes avec ce qui est la littérature
française de ce moment là et c'est pas
facile de se faire comprendre
quand même cette ambition qui est qui
est omniprésente je parle aussi de
évidemment de mon rêve de ski ne
s'accomplira jamais mais d'être d'être
un rentier vous savez de vivre justement
sans soucis d'argent dans le luxe et je
raconte que finalement j'ai eu toujours
des très belles maisons mais c'était
toujours les maisons des autres et en
même temps ça a été une expérience
intéressante en soi ne peut être que de
raconter de faire revivre ces maisons et
ses personnages qui ont d'une certaine
façon en chanter ma vie même si c'était
avec des lieux qui ne m'appartenait pas
mais en somme
dans ce livre bon il ya trois grandes
parties il ya une première partie qui
est vraiment sur les enchantements de
l'enfance ces expériences qui très jeune
dans la nature dans certains lieux avec
certaines personnes vous vous façonne
vous forge éveil votre sensibilité et
qui reviennent tout au long de la vie
parce que aujourd'hui encore j'y pense
souvent jeu dès que j'arrive danser dans
cette campagne vosgienne avec ses
ruisseaux qui sortent de la forêt ça je
me sens mieux je me sens chez moi je me
sens revivre et ça c'est vraiment la
chose que j'essaie de faire comprendre
la pratique du livre et puis la seconde
partie c'est les fils de la carrière
alors le fils de l'argent et il est un
peu au deuxième plan mais il ya aussi le
fils de certains combats par exemple
dans le domaine
de la musique de la musique moderne il
ya le film c'est vrai qu'on s'y arrête
parce que vous avez vos croisade
on pourrait dire par ailleurs bref
allusion à paris votre croisade pour que
paris ne semblait disent pas davantage
je lui avais consacré plusieurs livres
ça s'est perdu dans cette émission pour
en parler d'ailleurs et c'était le sujet
de la photo vous avez choisi mais il ya
votre croisade dans le domaine de la
musique contre pierre boulez le pape de
la musique contemporaine que vous osé
attaquer je dois dire à une époque où
c'est quasiment impossible de le faire
où il ya une véritable chape de plomb en
france sur ce qu'est et ce que doit être
la musique contemporaine et vous êtes
véritablement le seul à ce moment là
avec jean-françois de l'eagle votre ami
d'ailleurs et vous le raconter un peu
dans ce livre mais j'aimerais vous ne
vous en disiez plus parce que c'était
vraiment courageux on vous a traité de
nazillons à l'époque mais je suis sûr
que vous en avez que l'on veut attaquer
bien plus durement que cela alors
d'abord là encore je remet les choses à
leur place parce que la première partie
du livre dans ses vacances volkan j'y
mets en valeur mon grand oncle qui était
un héros de la résistance qui fait toute
mon admiration et qui va être un peu le
modèle de mon enfance et j'explique que
mes combats d'adultes sont quand même à
côté des combats et qu'on va vraiment
héroïque de la résistance sont des
combats assez modeste néanmoins
effectivement ce combat musical il était
quand même pas d'une violence physique
mais d'une violence intellectuelle
extrêmement forte et j'essaie de
d'expliquer dans ce livre en fête
comment tout est né pour moi d'un amour
passionné dévorant de la musique qui est
très présent dans tout le livre et
notamment de la musique moderne parce
que j'ai toujours je me suis enchantée
très jeune pour stravinsky debussy
bartok messiaen toute cette musique qui
vraiment accompagner ma vie et il ya eu
ensuite la musique contemporaine qui se
voulait être une radicalisation de la
musique moderne mais beaucoup plus
dogmatique beaucoup plus sectaires à sa
façon et qui a été porté en particulier
en france par pierre boulez et j'ai
commencé par me intéressés puisque
j'avais ce goût de la modernité et puis
je me suis aperçu qu'en fait c'était une
espèce de 6
m académique autoritaire et qu'en plus
le résultat je dirais purement
esthétique était était loin d'être
convaincant d'ailleurs là presque rien
de cette musique là cinquante soixante
ans après n'est finalement vraiment
entrer dans une sorte de répertoire
contrairement à toutes les autres
périodes de la musique
donc voilà j'ai eu cette expérience très
subjectif d'abord et j'ai commencé le
combat si je dois si j'ose dire à un
moment où en france vraiment les milieux
boulet wiens avait toute autorité sur la
presse musicale à la radio les grandes
institutions musicales et on a commencé
effectivement avec jean françois zygel
on avait 25 25 30 ans à lancer des
polémiques à dire à démonter les oeuvres
a montré que c'était pas super moderne
mais que c'était en réalité academy que
c'était un système moderne qui finissait
par être une sorte de pompier risma sa
façon et alors là qu'est ce qu'on
n'avait pas osé dire c'est immédiatement
qui est apparue cette réponse c'est très
théorique on a vu dans tous les domaines
dès qu'on s'en prend à une partie de la
modernité depuis ces dernières décennies
qui est vous êtes fasciste si vous
n'aimez pas ça c'est que vous êtes
nostalgique si vous êtes nostalgique
c'est que vous êtes réac si vous êtes
très axé que vous êtes fasciste c'est
une rhétorique un peu un peu stalinien
et ça nous est tombé dessus violemment
je me rappelle un article sur moi
effectivement dans libé que c'était bien
dégagée sur les oreilles je me rappelle
le monde me comparant à faurisson quand
même un fallait aller le faire avec
heureusement des gens comme comme claude
lévi-strauss et d'autres qui ont tout de
suite pris ma défense mais voilà ça a
été un combat violent et évidemment avec
un refus total de dialogue de la de
l'adversaire alors même que notre propos
étaient plutôt de mettre en valeur
d'autres aspects de la musique
contemporaine parce qu'on était à nous
très passionné de steve reich de phil
glass est certaine la mairie des mées de
semblait beaucoup plus convaincant dont
on entend parler aujourd'hui qu'ils ont
énormément de succès mais qui à l'époque
était quasiment interdit de séjour en
france
il faut bien voir boulez faisait la
pluie et le beau temps et
et s'il faisait la grande carrière de
chef d'orchestre à l'étranger il
il s'en servait pour faire croire qu'il
était un compositeur révéré absolument
sur toute la planète ce qui était
totalement faux il y avait que nous qui
pensions enfin nous les autorités en
fusion qu'il était un grand compositeur
alors qu' il ne l'était nullement c'est
ça parce que il se trouve que en plus la
culture musicale des élites françaises
est assez faible dans l'ensemble donc
voila vous laisse diriger à byron boulez
dirigé fort bien d'ailleurs beaucoup de
grandes oeuvres et de grands orchestres
en disque est donc pour les milieux
parisiens voilà il avait un grand succès
donc c'était le grand monsieur musique
ce conte oublié c'est que effectivement
sa musique elle n'existait pas et que le
combat très dur qui l'avait mené pendant
tant d'années
c'était au nom de sa de sa propre
musique est effectivement là est ce que
vous dites aussi c'est vrai que cette
nouvelle musique qui s'est imposé
partout dans le monde que viennent
d'ailleurs d'ex-union soviétique avec
des gens comme schnittke arvo pärt etc
ou des états unis
cette véritable école moderne
contemporaine qui a un vrai public elle
l était quasiment interdite de séjour en
france je me rappelle être entendre à
londres un festival alfred schmid que
c'était un compositeur interdit ici et
quand philip glass avait donné au
festival d'avignon et au festival
d'automne son opéra einstein on the
beach
on avait parlé dans la presse française
que de la mise en scène de bob wilson
parce que bob wilson avait la carte de
l'avant garde mais la musique de fil
grâce qui frayait en plus avec la pop
etc
considérée comme une chose absolument
absolument ignobles et donc voilà on a
on a un peu remué les choses et on a
fini dans une certaine mesure par paru
accomplir quelques conquêtes pour
élargir un peu le goût et le droit à
l'expression et ça a été un combat que
j'explique dans ce livre est que
j'élargis dans ce livre parce que
finalement derrière toutes mes
expériences il ya quand même cette idée
y compris littéraire d'ailleurs que
cette idée qu'il y à une modernité
dogmatique une seconde modernité qui a
confisqué l'esprit moderne alors que
l'esprit moderne et est aventureux qu'il
était fondée sur le sens critique sur
l'insolence aujourd'hui il ya une espèce
de modernité beaucoup plus autoritaire
qui interdit
toute forme de critique de la société
contemporaine et ses valeurs au nom de
la modernité nous c'est exactement le
contraire vous voulez faire vous voulez
retrouver une forme d'esprit critique et
d'insolence j'ai l'impression que c'est
un peu la même chose qui vous a guidé
dans votre rapport à ce qu'on pourrait
appeler la culture homosexuelle vous
dites dans votre livre que vous n'avez
jamais été attirée sexuellement par les
femmes mais que vous avez toujours
considéré l'hétérosexualité comme plus
normale entre guillemets que le l'été
que l'homosexualité qui est à vos yeux
un décalage une différence que vous
cultivez donc vous êtes assez fier mais
ça s'arrête là après de vouloir en faire
un système au fond de sa vous êtes
totalement étranger vous l'avait
racontée dans de nombreux articles dans
plusieurs livres notamment dans gaieté
parisienne vous êtes opposé au mariage
pour tous a à même à l'idée même aux
mauvais coups que vous n'aimez pas et ça
aussi c'était un peu courageux parce que
vous étiez vous étiez pas très nombreux
alors d'ailleurs je me suis pas opposé
au mariage pour tous mais je n'ai pas
milité pour c'est moi qu'on puisse dire
je trouvais ça absolument superflue et
j'avais l'impression et j'ai toujours
que c'est une espèce de conflits des
anciens et des modernes que ce qu'on a
voulu imposer en france pour des raisons
politiques
à l'époque c'était françois hollande et
cetera qui ont tellement d'autres
domaines étaient étaient impuissants que
tout d'un coup on relance est une espèce
de pseudo grandes luttes alors qu'à mon
avis on aurait très bien pu se contenter
d'une chose qui à mon avis beaucoup plus
moderne qui est le pacs et qui donnait à
tout le monde le même droit d'une forme
d'union civile d'ailleurs j'avais signé
même la une des premières pétitions pour
se réadapter le cul qu'à l'époque était
porté par didier eribon des gens dont je
suis très éloigné par ailleurs mais
parce que ça me paraissait bien voilà
une forme d'union civile pour que des
gens puissent s'entraider
le mariage ça me semblait être
finalement créé un conflit politique et
sociale qui était dont on aurait pu se
passer
mais c'est vrai que d'une façon plus
générale et j'en viens à ce que je
disais sur la musique effectivement j'ai
l'impression qu'il ya eu un mouvement
d'émancipation extrêmement courageux
des homosexuels qui a commencé à l'aube
du xxème siècle notamment on pourrait
citer gide on pourrait citer oscar wilde
ans pourrait citer beaucoup d'autres
acteurs de cette émancipation et que ça
c'est voilà c'est une chose que je
revendique si j'ose dire en tout cas que
ce qui m'apparaissait comme une forme de
progrès de liberté de la liberté et puis
effectivement on est arrivé à des
espèces de mouvements militants radicaux
qui s'approprie la voix homosexuels sans
qu'on sache d'ailleurs vraiment bien
qu'il représente une espèce de lobby
associatifs comme ça qu'ils en demandent
toujours plus qui prétend effectivement
exercer un contrôle du langage des mots
qu'on a le droit de dire un certain
nombre de choses et c est là ça devient
effectivement un dogmatisme sectaire à
tel point que j'ai vu d'ailleurs même
parmi des amis journalistes homosexuels
certains qui finissaient par admettre
l'idée me paraissait scandaleuse que
avoir une opinion critique sur le
mariage gay s'était déjà être homophobe
donc on ne pouvait plus et comme
l'homophobie était réprimée par la loi
ne pouvait plus émettre la moindre forme
de critique voilà sur une évolution des
institutions c'est le passage de la
modernité
l'idée libérant tu as une modernité
dogmatique et sectaire que j'obtiens
aussi dans le domaine du féminisme par
exemple et dans beaucoup d'autres
domaines et c'est effectivement
peut-être l'arrière-plan de ma vie dans
votre beaucoup de domaines oui parce que
j'ai l'impression que vous luttez au
fond contre une forme d'académisme ce
qui était une culture et un comportement
une vie sulfureuse différente originale
audacieuse tout à coup ça devient bon
quelque chose au fond d' extrêmement
hétéronormée quoi voilà et ont
d'ailleurs oui c'est cette volonté y
compris évidemment de recréer le modèle
familial dont les homosexuels ont voulu
pendant longtemps s'émanciper alors on
va dire voilà c'est des idées de vieux
gauchiste est assez rare qu'on traite de
gauchistes mais en l'occurrence oui
effectivement il veut sexualité voulait
s'affranchir de la famille retrouvé une
forme de liberté etc et aujourd'hui on
est exactement dans le contraire dans la
revendication absolue d'une norme
incritiquable indifférencié de tout le
reste et je trouve ça oui un petit peu
ou un petit peu dommage parce que la
réalité elle nous rattrape toujours et
la réalité
qu'on le veuille ou non elle est bien là
et la réalité c'est que la sexualité
hétérosexuelle est et sera toujours
majoritaire et la sexualité homosexuelle
sera toujours en marge minoritaires et
posera toujours des questions pour cette
raison à ce je dirais à qui ça arrive
sans qu'il ait forcément voulu ni
chercher et qui se retrouve dans cette
situation et ça ça les interroge ils
sont forcément un petit peu à côté et il
faut l'accepter ne pas l'accepter c'est
simplement nier nier la réalité mais on
peut très bien vivre avec et fort
heureusement on vit dans une société qui
ne réprime plus c'est pratique mais est
ce qu'il faut pour autant nier toute
différence entre tous et tout ce qui est
la tendance est effectivement les
théories poste genre etc et autres jeux
at-il benoît duteurtre qu'avec des des
combats comme cela est contre les cuves
sont devenus les gares de chemin de fer
la capitale les l'avenue de l'opéra
vous êtes vont laisser enfermer dans une
espèce d tiken de réactionnaires qui
quand on veut qu'adam vous correspond
pas du tout mais qui est souvent l'image
que l'on êtes vous avant de vous
rencontrer
est-ce que ça n'est pas la raison pour
laquelle en font
vous avez du mal à vous faire prendre au
sérieux en tant qu'écrivain certainement
mais je veux dire ce jeu d'abord comme
je l'expliquais propres la musique ce
jeu de vous coller l'étiquette
réactionnaire en plus la france à pékin
vient des étiquettes et que vous avez un
propos critiques et de vous la coller à
vie
c'est effectivement une stratégie de si
j'ose dire de mes adversaires elle est
pratique puisqu'on vit dans une époque
dont la valeur c'est la modernité si on
voudrait du réactionnaire vous êtes
exclu du champ cela dit je leur dis et
je les pensais toute ma vie jusqu'à
présent en tout cas c'est que justement
je pense que je suis précisément un
moderne parce que le moderne c'est
l'esprit critique c'est la remise en
cause des choses établies c'est
l'insolence par rapport à une espèce
d'ordre du monde donc je pense qu'en
critiquant ce qui est devenu la
mondialité je suis moi en réalité un
moderne mais effectivement il m'a fallu
tout toute ma vie lutter contre cette
étiquette dont je vous remercie de dire
qu'elle me ressemble au fond pas
tellement mais effectivement qui m'a qui
m'a poursuivi parce que on est quand
même dans un pays très voilà où les
choses sont de recentrer tranché je
citerai pas les titres de presse par
exemple qui parce qu'ils sont dominés
par une pensée qui serait éloignée de la
mienne n'ont jamais fait la moindre
allusion à mes romans ou fin à la
carrière littéraire j'ai heureusement
été bien défendus par d'autres mais il
ya quand même une façon voilà de vous
enfermer politiquement y compris dans le
champ littéraire et culturelle qui est
un peu un peu pénible fort heureusement
voilà les les choses ont évolué parce
que assas a ajouté je le raconte
effectivement le sentiment d'être un peu
seul dans les années 90 quand j'essayais
d'écrire des romans sur la france
contemporaine des romans à ces critiques
et sarcastique comme tout doit
disparaître et d'autres livres voilà où
je tournais un petit peu en dérision ce
qui était en train de devenir notre
société et ce n'était pas du tout dans
le but lui dire air du temps on était
dans le culte de l'écriture justement
cette chose a hérité de l'avant garde
etc
il fallait créer des écritures créer des
écritures et ç'a passé complètement à
côté
et puis heureusement les choses ont
changé il ya eu notamment l'arrivée de
houellebecq était pour moi un peu
salutaire parce que il a imposé par ses
succès et son talent l'idée qu'il y
avait effectivement une nouvelle
littérature en france qui s'intéressait
au monde à la société aux changements de
la société comme balzac en sentant
s'était intéressée aux changements de la
société et que là il y avait tout un
champ littéraire peut être beaucoup plus
intéressant que celui de l'écriture pour
l'écriture est donc dans ce sens là
la cause à laquelle je crois avoir
contribué moi aussi à ce moment-là a
quand même beaucoup gagné par rapport à
ce que c'était au début des années 90
mais vous avez souffert par ailleurs
d'une forme de légèreté qui vous
caractérise par rapport à houellebecq
par exemple houellebecq c'est vraiment
oui c'est presque morbide c'est c'est
grave c'est c'est tragique
c'est la mort ou lt mélancolique en tout
cas c'est la mort vous vous êtes vivant
vous êtes léger et au fond vous êtes
souvent apparenté au divertissement
ben oui alors c'est vrai que j'ai fait
ce bout depuis toujours de d'une culture
voilà de la légèreté du divertissement
mais mes modèles littéraires si j'ose
dire il ya un molière évidemment que
j'aime depuis l'enfance il ya aussi par
exemple la comédie italienne j'ai
toujours adoré ça cette façon ce regard
aigu comme ça sur les transformations
des rapports sociaux dans les années 50
tous ces films de monicelli de comencini
j'ai toujours adoré ça il ya sempé qui
est un quelqu'un que qui quand j'avais
15 ans me passionner plus que les
romanciers de l'époque parce que j'avais
l'impression qu'il avait tout vu sur les
changements du monde mais avec cette
fantaisie et cette légèreté et que
j'aime alphonse allais et puis j'aime
marcel aymé donc c'est vrai que je suis
dans une lignée sans doute effectivement
qui est plus de la fantaisie et de
légèreté et malheureusement ça peut
paraître un peu cliché mais c'est aussi
gros que ça c'est qu'on prend toujours
plus au sérieux quelqu'un qui vit à
l'air de dire des choses très sérieuses
et très lourde et très intérieur est
très douloureuse que quelqu'un qui a
l'air de blaguer avec avec la réalité
donc effectivement ça peut être
considéré par beaucoup comme un défaut
mais je m'attache à 7
cette tradition car à côté en plus ça
c'est assez français
voilà vous vous raconter d'ailleurs
votre rencontre avec sempé il vous aime
bien santé ah bah oui il a fait plein de
couverture pour mes livres et j'étais
c'était un dieu pour moi parce que je
vous dise déjà petit avc album chez mes
grands-parents donc pour moi c'était
comme ça une espèce de mythe vivant et
surtout ses visions des villes des
transformations des villes ou du type
qui part à la campagne pour oublier
qu'il verra industrielle puis il ya la
campagne commence à produire des choux
et jusqu à ce qu il redevienne un
industriel y avait un regard comme ça
toujours sarcastique décalé et très
social qui me fascinait et puis un jour
j'ai eu la chance de rencontrer j'ai été
tout surpris parce que c'était un homme
encore relativement jeune sportif était
terrain et on est devenue amies il a
fait des très jolies couvertures pour
plusieurs de mes romans on est parti en
voyage ensemble et j'étais très très
fier de rencontrer ce merveilleux
artistes donc en plus j'avais admiré
chez lui les dessins j'avais toujours vu
dans des albums qui en fait sont souvent
des immenses dessin c'est pour ça que
chacun de ces petits personnages à tant
de vies et de caractère et voilà ça a
été pour moi une grande joie que de que
de devenir son ami sur le tard vous avez
souvent d'ailleurs d'aider des gens
comme ça qui vous qui vous font un clin
d'oeil au moment où les autres ont l'air
de vous détestez il ya mis un coup de
dera aussi à guy debord également lee de
bord c'est plus sinon que sempé ou
kundera alors cessé en plus ça me fait
plaisir vous me posez cette question
parce que j'entends des gens dire une
émission de radio où l'un des
chroniqueurs il ironisait un peu ce fait
ah oui il nous dit qu'il a reçu une
carte postale de kundera qu'est ce que
ça peut nous faire alors là encore je
remet ça en situation dans le livret
dans l'auto ironie et dans
l'autoportrait
c'est vrai que ce que je raconte surtout
c'est que j'ai écrit un roman quand
j'avais 30 ans qui s'appelait tout doit
disparaître et qui n'avait eu absolument
aucun succès mise à part deux ou trois
journalistes je ne citerai pas qu'ils
ont généreusement soutenu qu'ils étaient
un peu de ma génération d'ailleurs et
s'était passé vraiment complètement à
côté et j'étais assez désespérée c'était
mon troisième livre ce n'est pas que
j'allais beaucoup à new york j'en parle
souvent dans le temps dans ma vie
extraordinaire mon attachement dur je
suis parti pour un long séjour à new
york puis su rentrer en france
voilà un peu
un peu d'effets par l'échec de ce livre
j'avais mis beaucoup de moi même et
c'est vrai que j'ai trouvé là dans ma
boîte aux lettres de cartes postales de
deux personnes à qui j'avais envoyé le
livre mais sans les connaître du tout et
sans imaginer qu'elle le lirai qui était
une de milan kundera
j'ai beaucoup beaucoup aimé votre livre
etc sur une carte postale d'un tableau
de fernand léger précieusement gardés et
l'autre de guy debord effectivement sur
une carte postale qui représentait le
fameux mur du quartier saint germain où
il avait écrit ne travaillez jamais etc
et c'était ça va sauver d'une certaine
façon parce que mon livre n'avait eu
aucun succès mais d'avoir tout d'un coup
ses deux petits signes de deux hommes
que j'admirais ça va ça va requinquer en
tout cas pour pas mal d'années et de
bord oui évidemment il ya tout un côté
comme assimilerait chez les
situationnistes une forme peut-être de
de gauchisme etc mais c'est quand même
beaucoup plus complexe que ça c'est
quelqu'un qui a été aussi parmi les
premiers à voir justement les impasses
de d'une certaine modernité et de
l'avant-garde a critiqué l'urbanisme
contemporain
il ya même dans les premiers numéros de
l'internationale situationniste des
critiques de la musique contemporaine de
l'époque c'est des gens qui avaient vu
beaucoup plus loin que justement la
simple le simple analyse d'extrême
gauche qu'on pouvait faire alors sur le
sur la société sur le progrès sur le
monde de l'art ma vie extraordinaire
c'est le nouveau livre de benoît
duteurtre qui vient de paraître chez
gallimard merci benoît je vous remercie
tous les deux d'avoir participé à cette
émission
merci de nous avoir suivis et rendez
vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]